bonsoir nous sommes le 7 juillet 2015
bienvenue si vous venez de nous
rejoindre sur tv fil 78 tu vois si votre
journal d'actualités locales et parmi
les titres les sujets qui seront à
développer aujourd'hui après de longues
semaines de révision après six jours
d'examens stressant les candidats au bac
sont fixés depuis ce matin donc si on
rattrapage ou nouvelle année de
bachotage pour certains le point sur les
résultats dans notre académie il était
chargé d'assurer la promotion du sport
dans les yvelines jean loup le plat
président du comité départemental
olympique et sportif vient d'annoncer
son retrait de son nom d'ice expliquera
tout à l'heure en plateau et puis
sportissimo c'est le nom du nouvel
ouvrage de bernard delattre journalistes
pendant près de 40 ans il revient sur
cette passion est sûre c'est rencontre
de pelé azila notamment l'occasion de
parler des valeurs du sport mais aussi
est de ces dérives sociales pour débuter
depuis le 10 juin depuis presque un mois
maintenant dans les yvelines ce sont
plus de 400 travailleurs sans papiers
qui sont anglais avec qui occupent les
locaux des agences d'intérim comme celle
d'adecco ici à saint quentin en yvelines
mais aussi à manpower aux mureaux ou
encore à l' agence randstad de poissy
ces travailleurs réclament des
attestations de concordance à leurs
employeurs qui n'ont toujours pas donné
suite à leur demande d'entretien
nous sommes des travailleurs sans
papiers et nous revendiquons des
attestations de concordance pour
valoriser notre travail et des
attestations
comme promis ce tambour donc au delà de
300 d'isère en tant qu'intérimaire on a
droit a obtenu cette promesse était
moche mais jusqu'à présent les enseignes
telles que adecco manpower et randstad
refuse encore ces attestations
depuis qu'on est venu on était là
pacifiquement les a pas empêchés de
travailler
il nous avait fait au début une
assignation et on auprès du tribunal de
grande instance de versailles
on a remporté
l'audition là on est là on n'est pas en
france pour quémander
on a travaillé on a cotisé donc on a
droit a obtenu ces attestations
des propos recueillis par william elle
délivrance pour certains révision pour
d'autres les candidats au bac dans les
yvelines ont appris ce matin à 10h leurs
résultats aux différentes épreuves
retour sur cette matinée avec mélanie
poquet elodie moine il n'est pas encore
10 heures devant le lycée de villars
huayi en cours et les candidats trépigne
les résultats ne vont pas tarder à être
affichée
une détente
c'est une nouvelle vie t'es pas jusqu'à
là mais c'est quand même un bon jour
j'ai eu la mention assez bien
donc ça va je suis content et on va ça
fait du bien quand même de la voir
passer un piment maintenant bas on pense
à autre chose on est trop cottin tu es
c'était dur mais c'est c'est trop bien
en fait faut travailler puis c'est
faisable et entre les lauréats et les
parents parfois difficile de savoir qui
est le plus ému je pense que j'étais
peut-être même un peu plus stressé que
lui et ému ouais mais j'avais j'ai versé
ma larme donc je pense que non c'est le
bac maintenant c'est quand même c'est
quelque chose il faut la voir
donc c'est important voilà une bonne
chose de faite
heureux le travail a payé
donc c'est une belle journée je pense
que ça va être une belle journée de
décompression un parent après tout ce
stress des cris des rires mais aussi des
larmes pour ceux qui ne sont pas admis
si la moyenne se situe entre 8 et 10 sur
20 rien n'est pas encore perdu je vais
aller réviser mercat parce que comme ça
c'est le plus gros colère c'est donc je
pourrais le rattraper et j'espère la
voir demain je veux dire être
directement à la voir bach dont je suis
un peu énervé et déçu les épreuves de
rattrapage se déroule jusqu'au vendredi
10 juillet dans les yvelines plus de 13
mille six cents candidats ont passé les
épreuves du baccalauréat cette année
pour les filières générales et
technologiques
l'heure des résultats au bac et bientôt
aussi les inscriptions en faculté ou en
école supérieure et pour beaucoup pour
certains en tout cas la recherche d'un
logement un forum était organisé à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
pendant toute une matinée le week end
dernier 4 et du gâteau et mélanie poker
marlène vient du perche pour faire des
études de bts tourisme trouver un
logement quand on est étudiant pas si
simple il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
demandent des logements ici
donc pour nous c'est pas facile et n'est
pas la seule dans ce cas il ya trop de
demandes du coup vous avez pêchées au
côté financier c'est pas toujours
évident les loyers sont quand même
relativement cher ensuite il ya aussi le
fait que ben on va s'asseoir après vous
avez les propriétaires peut-être pouvoir
négocier avec eux que les coûts sont
variables dont les résonances
conventionnés ça tourne autour de 400 à
500 euros à peu près après sur le
logement vraiment privé c'est beaucoup
plus cher avec soin des frais d'entrée
en plus pour aiguiller les étudiants un
forum logement il est organisé à
l'université dans un même lieu ces
derniers pouvaient trouver des
informations auprès de tous les
partenaires une plate forme a été mise
en place par la communauté
d'agglomération la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a lancé une nouvelle plateforme
de mise en relation les propriétaires
privés des étudiants qui est sky point
look avis ce point est fait et donc nous
on travaille vraiment partenariat avec
la casse qui est toutes les offres en
fait qu'ils sont saisis sur ce site on a
la main en fait dessus on peut les
consulter les communiqués aux étudiants
les propriétaires privés sont aussi
invités à proposer des chambres
ils sont 250 chaque année à offrir une
solution on va le renseigner sur comment
rédiger un contrat de location qui soit
conforme à la nouvelle loi qui est paru
l'année dernière la loi allure
ensuite toutes les précautions à prendre
vis-à-vis d'un étudiant les garanties
au niveau des cautions du dépôt de
garantie l'offre de logement étudiant a
triplé en cinq ans sur la zone de
nouvelles constructions ont été terminés
au togo vélodrome avec 300 nouvelles
places
des projets sont également en cours à la
verrière et aiguille en cours un tout
autre sujet à présent je reçois jean
loup le plat bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le président du cnoss le comité
départemental olympique vous avez
annoncé votre retrait de cette fonction
fin juin ou étiez en poste depuis 12 ans
et les attaques sont plutôt lourde vous
dit notamment que votre instance n'est
plus reconnu comme représentant le
mouvement sportif yvelinois pourquoi ça
oui parce qu'effectivement ce retrait je
crois les se manifeste à travers deux
points tout d'abord c'est un acte
protestataires et en deuxième c'est un
acte d' alerte
pourquoi un acte protestataires parce
que effectivement le cas c'est quand
même le représentant du mouvement
sportif dans les yvelines
soixante comité plus 400 mille licenciés
sportifs
n'oublions pas que les fonds du cndf le
sentiment du sport proviennent des
droits télévisuels de retransmission des
médiations sportivité paris du pmu donc
on pense qu'on aurait pu faire un petit
peu mieux quant aux subventions il m'a
été donné alors je vous rappelle
simplement mais vous savez il ya un
article dans tout cas il ya peu de temps
moins 15000 euros du côté du conseil
départemental et moins de 1000 euros
du côté du cnds en l'état actuel des
choses pissos est un acte d' alerte
parce qu'effectivement ces situations on
va entendre et vraisemblablement une
situation déficits et en fin d'exercice
2015 et je pense que 29 kg euros de
subventions en moins pour un budget d'à
peu près cent mille euros c'est quand
même beaucoup
et puis il est probable que cette
situation déficitaire va s'aggraver car
on nous a mis une très forte pression
pour embaucher un ou deux salariés avec
les fonds du cnds les fonds aider mais
il faut savoir qu'un emploi si on nous
donne effectivement 12000 euros à titre
d' aide financière cela coûte tout de
même de 30 à 40 mille euros envoyé un
différentiel de 18 la matu 1000 euros
fait problème est financier
mais joël comme m'attarder sur ce qu'ils
font
on va parler de cette pression vous
subissez juste pour préciser les choses
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent
quelles sont les attributions du cnoss
justement quelles sont les missions que
vous devez normalement si tout va bien
mené vous avez raison il faut rappeler
que les missions du gloss sont multiples
d'abord c'est comme je le disais
représenter le moment sportif auprès des
pouvoirs publics à ce que la préfecture
la ddcs le conseiller parlementaire et
bientôt c'est également d'assurer la
formation des dirigeants des bénévoles
des éducateurs s'assurer la promotion du
sport à travers des manifestations
telles que les fous les olympiques tels
que la sport olympique
et puis c'est aussi faire vivre les
principes de l'eau n'a pu mener à bien
d'autres mais enfin je voudrais citer
les principaux vous avez évoqué ses
moyens financiers
difficile en tout cas les difficultés
que vous rencontrez je reviens sur ces
pressions énormes de qui viennent ces
pressions et pourquoi ces embauches
pourquoi on vous forcée qui vous force à
faire des embauches alors encore une
fois bon on l'a bien compris si vous
voulez qu en france il ya un problème
d'emploi il faut aider les jeunes à
trouver un emploi et c'est pour ça qu'au
gouvernement on a fait une priorité
nationale ce que le mouvement sportif
comprend fort bien la question c'est que
pour embaucher il faut avoir les moyens
d'embaucher
et comme je vous le disais même si on
nous donne une aide de 12 mille euros
par emploi il faudrait qu'on m'explique
et personne n'a su me l'expliquer jusqu
alors comment on peut arriver à financer
un emploi qui coule de 30 à 40 milles
c'est les voies publiques au niveau des
pouvoirs publics des instances plus
haute dans l'état on vous dit ça serait
bien et c'est la même chose que
conseiller brochet embauché ça nous at
il répété à de nombreuses reprises pour
quel poste bas on ne sait pas justement
c'est aussi c'est un peu le problème qui
compte je pense et l'amélioration des
statistiques du chômage donc
effectivement à partir du moment où on
prend un emploi c'est très bien ça fait
plus simple dans les stats mais pour
autant ça ne règle pas notre problème de
financement
les poids aussi on pourrait imaginer on
doit parler de sport santé hommes de la
parler de féminisation du sport nous a
parlé a fait des missions bike du quator
portif je précise quand même que nous on
n'est pas sur le terrain immédiatement
on est au dessus du terrain au-dessus
des clubs au dessus des comités donc on
est quand même plutôt des généralistes
voilà quelle menace plane avec cette
stat cette situation au dessus du duc
dos vous dit ce n'est plus reconnu comme
représentant du
mon sportif yvelinois quelle est la
menace qui pèse sur le sport globalement
bas pour moi je vais réfléchir par
rapport à nous je mentionné par rapport
à nous et nous on aimerait bien quand
même que représentant le mouvement
sportif yvelinois nous soyons considérés
comme tel on a l'impression à travers
ces distorsions de subventions qu'on
n'est plus vraiment reconnus comme tels
et à partir du moment où effectivement
on nous met la pression pour en boucher
comment va-t-on faire pour
financièrement arrivé à assumer ces
embauches si on bouche il devait y avoir
vous êtes en retrait vous ne
démissionnait pas c'est un retrait vous
l'aidiez c'est à la fois un à l'élagage
de serre c'est à dire que l'année
dernière bah écoutez moi je considère
qu'il ya un dommage imminent qui se
profile et je souhaite éviter ce dommage
imminent et c'est pour ça je préfère me
retirer j'alerte très clairement sur le
sort futur du club sur leurs piquets
sportive des yvelines mais si elle si la
donne évolué si les choses changent si
les budgets revienne si vous avez les
garanties des assurances remboursent à
une bonne question vous à lui noté que
très récemment le mouvement sportif et
olympique franciliens cette fois ci a à
l'unanimité de ses comités le celi
décidé de ne pas voter de ne pas
participer au vote des attributions de
subventions qui ont eu lieu lors de la
commission territoriale de vendredi
dernier à la direction régionale
jeunesse et sports et cohésion sociale
et à l'unanimité jeudi bien le mouvement
sportif s'est retirée donc on pourrait
imaginer qu'on revienne aux chants des
discussions ça serait bien
et moi je souhaite qu'effectivement on
revienne à des choses plus sérieuses qui
me permette d'assurer le financement du
sport des emplois pas de démission parce
que si on vient vous proposez discuter
nord-ouest est fine et je me retire
c'est clair la couverture est bon je ne
reviendrai pas non je ne reviendrai pas
où je suis très claire il ya une équipe
dirigeante qui pendant la suite vous
assumez vous avez été en poste pendant
12 ans il ya une déception malgré tout
non non ça fait partie de la vie vous
savez je crois il faut s'attendre
des choses comme ça c'est une prise de
position je la prends bien volontiers ma
foi je n'ai aucun regret à cet égard je
pense avoir fait ce qu'il fallait faire
c'est un acte de gestion aussi parce que
je ne vois pas comment j'aurais pu
signer des actes qui juridiquement et
financièrement aurait engagé mais mes
successeurs gonze je ne le souhaitais
pas vous attirez impliqué dans le monde
sportif avant même le kiosque est ce que
vous avez été sportif vous même oui
étoile avait voulu qu'il nombreux sports
vous et vous me disiez il n'y a pas de
déception vous avez le sentiment d'avoir
mené à bien vos différentes missions
vous qui étiez venu un petit peu par
hasard à la présidence du club le tout
revient sur l'historique oui c'est vrai
vous étiez avec oman à la présidence
voyez vous une anecdote je pense que
certains la connaissent un jour où
j'allais au conseil général en ce temps
là c'est comme ça qu'on appelait il y
avait des personnes qui par ce penalty
mais général d'yveline information
jeunesse est dans le couloir voyez
l'histoire se répète me tiens voilà le
comité directeur du glaude bien
démissionner
on cherche vraiment un prêt dix ans et
puis bah voilà on est ma mère ce soit
toi et le soir 19 heures j'étais eu à
chevaux voilà comment ça s'est passé
vous regrettez pas un non pas du tout
c'était une histoire une vie
passionnante
impressionnant très bien merci beaucoup
jean leplat je voudrais placer sur ce
plateau nous expliquer les raisons de ce
retrait les inquiétudes que vous avez
également
pour le dos pour le comité départemental
olympique merci à vous et puis comme
vous aimez le sport vous serez sans
doute intéresser tout à l'heure par le
témoignage de notre prochaine invitée
c'est bernard delattre il est auteur de
sportissimo il parle des valeurs du
sport mais aussi de ces dérives ce sera
dans quelques minutes mais déjà loisirs
elle samedi dernier lieu l'événement
voisins des îles au jardin eugène
fleuret cette avance avant le bretonneux
une journée pour mettre à l'honneur les
cultures d'outre-mer plus de 200
personnes et de nombreuses associations
y ont assisté
voisin des îles un voyage vers
l'outre-mer avec ses stands exotiques sa
musique et ses danses le centre alfred
de vigny a fait partager les cultures et
les traditions des antilles de la guyane
de la réunion et de la martinique aux
jardins eugène fleuret à
voisins-le-bretonneux cette journée
voisins d hilary sous la chaleur des
îles aujourd'hui on a de la chance a
besoin elle est née d'un beau projet en
fait de toutes les associations
participantes et locales qui ont
souhaité faire manifestation autour de
résine neuf mois ont été nécessaires
pour organiser cette manifestation au
programme plusieurs activités
culturelles
il y a de la couture de la coiffure du
maquillage de la danse ce soir il y aura
des concerts avec les groupes et on
finira en beauté avec un dj pour un
petit peu dansé et bien sûr une grosse
partie alimentaire puisque on a trois
traiteurs qui sont à nos côtés pour
offrir les trésors gastronomiques de nos
régions un petit peu éloigné et des
trésors gastronomiques des produits
locaux des objets d'art mais aussi de la
danse et de la musique traditionnelle
des îles luciane rhino professeur de
danse et directrice de l'association toi
et moi est venu partager ses savoirs
faire c'est une association qui met en
valeur et bien la culture un petit peu
la culture africaine mais également la
culture caraïbes et caribéennes
les danses et également les bijoux et
les la tisane à le centre alfred de
vigny espère réaliser à nouveau cet
événement l'année prochaine
et puis d'autres animations pour la
troisième année consécutive la ville de
la verrière se mettait aux couleurs du
portugal à 7 organisé par une
association locale a eu lieu à dimanche
dernier au complexe philippe cousteau
au programme concerts plats
traditionnels bien sûr avec pour
objectif de rassembler les nouvelles
générations pour re découvrir cette
culture ballet l'événement de cette
journée déjà d'une c'est avoir un
festival dans l'année qui représente
donc le folklore de la barrière
donc après on réunit tous les groupes
plusieurs groupes des alentours de la
région parisienne
ce qui fait que il représente aussi à
leur ville du portugal
ça représente ce que nous on fait ce
qu'on nous faisait il ya quelques années
chez vous au portugal
tous les ans on avait un festival annuel
qui se faisait dans l'année donc c'est
ce qu'on veut représenter ici en france
on est le portugal ici à l'intérieur on
va pas l'emmener ici mais on veut on
veut surtout pas l'oublier en fait parce
que chez nous effectivement moi je suis
déjà une troisième à une troisième
génération dénégations et chez - a déjà
pratiquement ça se fait ça c'est encore
mais pas beaucoup
donc nous on a voulu continuer quelque
chose qui existe déjà chez nous et nous
comme on est une génération plus récente
on veut on veut quand même que ça ça
continue c'est que ça continue et qu'on
puisse nous nous enfants à nous puis
savoir d'où nous parents venez d'où nos
grands parents venez donc c'est surtout
pour cinq ans craig nous allons parler à
nouveau de sport à présent avec le
second invités de cette édition bernard
delattre bonsoir journalistes pendant
près de 40 ans vous étiez aux nouvelles
de rambouillet aujourd'hui vous vous
consacrer pleinement à la littérature et
vous publier un nouveau roman nouveau
livre aux éditions de l'harmattan il
s'intitule sportissimo courir marcher
naviguer c'est vivre plus fort
l'objectif avec cet ouvrage que l'on
voit à l'écran c'est de parler des
valeurs du sport de l'éthique aussi
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
inquiétude de voir disparaître tous à
véritablement ben oui da actuellement il
est de bon ton de dire que tout fout le
camp le foot ça va pour rien on veut
tout jeter alors faut pas oublier les
vraies valeurs du football moi c'est le
football qu'on aime c'est celui d'albert
camus quant à quitter quand même prix
nobel de littérature qui était gardien
de football universitaire à alger qui a
dit le peu d eux que ce que tu cèdes le
peu que je sais des êtres humains je
l'appris du football et qui a dit aussi
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits où on
peut être aussi heureux que dans un
stade
mais c'est vrai que toute dérive avec
les inquiétudes sont réelles attention
aux dérives un football trop bling bling
c'est ce que vous écrivez ce même en
grade
on l'a vu déjà même platini l'a dit qui
reconnaît plus football actuel le
football des années 60-70 de
saint-etienne de rocheteau même platini
à bron joueur de football professionnel
et gagner comme un ingénieur il roulait
pas en lamborghini c'était pas une star
là ya des dérives totale quoi dire qu'il
faut revenir aux valeurs dans les
immenses qu'il faut revenir un accès
possible
je pense que c'est de bon ton de le dire
aussi c'est bien
revenir mais est ce qu'on n'est pas dans
un système qui finalement fait que ce
sera difficile de regarder c'est
toujours possible de lui comme un bateau
dérive on revient retrouvez-les cap et
j'ai lu le livre de guy roule de
l'entraîneur d'auxerre de l'époque de
djibril cissé ils disent assez sega sega
au début de saison les gars l'aj auxerre
ne travaille pas pour des marques de
voitures allemandes ou italiennes donc
je vous interdit d'aller dans auxerre
avec vos lamborghini tout ça parce qu'à
auxerre il ya des gens qui ont du mal à
payer les places du stade donc par
respect pour eux ils n'allaient pas
auxerre avec les grosses voitures vous
allez à paris sous lui il y en a plus
beaucoup d guy roux aujourd'hui il ya
malheureusement un certain moment
c'était un vrai passionné un bosseur
aussi est ce que le sport féminin parce
que vous l'évoquez dans cet ouvrage le
sport féminin football féminin n'est pas
seulement permet de retrouver un petit
peu c'est ces valeurs on l'a vu avec le
succès au football au basket aussi il ya
des tas de très bons résultats et le
public adhère aussi mais le football
féminin était beaucoup suivi en
discutent avec des passionnés et
beaucoup de gens de ont découvert le
football féminin ils ont été étonnés la
qualité du jeu technique et moins avec
moins de trucage par un joueur de un
homme footballeur professionnel va avoir
tendance à tomber dans les 18 mètres
pour chercher le penalty les femmes le
font pas elles sont un pays aussi donc
voilà et tout ça vous en parler bien
évidemment dans sportissimo est ce que
c'est encore possible je vous ai posé la
question tout alarmés de voir se
réaliser ce message je vais le dire pour
vous provoquer un peu un peu naïf
finalement de de sport vecteur de paix
de respect est ce que c'est possible
mais je suis pas naïf comme vision et il
faut être un peu naïf un ace que mandela
était naïf on annonce un bain de sang
entre noirs et blancs en afrique du sud
lui après 27 ans de prison il pardonne
et ya la paix est ce qu'il est et naïf
ou pas non et il a réussi ce que je veux
dire j'ai une anecdote dans l'île soeur
emmanuelle que j'avais rencontré à
trappes
lors d'une rencontre inter
interreligieuse avec avec rachid benzine
elle avait dit quand l'été chiffonniers
du caire il y avait toutes les
communautés religieuses et chrétiens les
maronites les juifs des musulmans
chiites sunnites
ils se parlent pas comme partout ils se
parlent pas elles disaient ils ont des
problèmes de voisinage comme partout
elle disait quand il ya un problème à
régler
j'organisais quoi tournoi de football là
c'était le seul moment
c'est peut-être se parler et après le
tournoi elle faisait une rencontre
qu'ils aient commis mais bien pour
trouver une solution
ça voici un exemple et aussi en football
par an quand il y avait la guerre entre
l'argentine et l'angleterre la
produisent îles malouines on a quand
même fait le match de football dont vous
parlez de soeur emmanuelle parce que ce
livre est rempli de vos différentes
rencontres durant l'exercice de votre
profession journaliste sur ce secteur
yvelinois vous préservez fréquenté au
zidane aimé jacquet anelka aussi figure
originaire de trappes d'ailleurs sur un
an et le gars vous dites je sais qu'il a
bon coeur j'espère qu'il fera parler de
lui en bien
j'aime beaucoup et le cas mais pour moi
c'est il a un peu victime d'un système
lui c'est un gars qui joue bien au foot
moi j'ai vu débuter en équipe 2 du paris
saint germain il marqué trois buts
il partait du milieu du terrain pour moi
c'était un potentiel à l'appeler et tout
et puis après donc sa cote à monter mais
c'est pas de sa faute il s'est retrouvé
à voir une côte énorme et il était un
des plus gros transferts de l'époque et
ça a fait des jalousies ensuite et on
l'a incité à à bouger de club je pense
que s'il était resté plus longtemps en
angleterre il a avec arsène wenger il
aurait pu avoir une meilleure carrière
tout dépend du coach une fois depuis son
mariage qui ont connu une carrière
exceptionnelle a joué dans 7 pays il a
pratiquement peu été blessés il est
toujours là et je ressens vous êtes
passionné de sport il est question de
football mais pas uniquement on va y
venir rapidement mais la rencontre qui
vous a le plus marqué d'ailleurs parce
que vous êtes en photo avec aimé jacquet
je vais jamais me sembla j'ai concrétisé
de rêve c'était bon va rencontrer mais
jacquet et puis mon premier
semi-marathon c'était en 2004 c'est à
bullion pour les enfants malades et donc
aimé jacquet s'était lui aussi son
premier semi marathon et on a discuté de
foot pendant deux heures quoi c'est moi
jumeaux que je suis originaire de
gueugnon vieux parler de gueugnon et
beaucoup de rencontres il ya eu yannick
noah aussi finement avec l'équipe j'ai
vu à elancourt alors qu'ils venaient
comme musicien il débutait comme
chanteur il galérait parce qu'il n'était
pas connu et il n'avait pas rempli
palais des sports il n'y avait pas
remplie le prévenu encourt céder le
prisme d'un go rencontre aussi avec des
anonymes des
héros sportifs anonymes des sportifs
handicapés handisport ça c'est vraiment
des gens étonnants à rambouillet avait
le championnat du monde des athlètes de
petite taille à un esprit formidable
quoi et oui j'ai eu le fameux athlètes
tunisiens là sa maman avait pris des
produits si bien qu'il était né sans
pieds et avec une seule main ce gars là
il a fait 3-1 jeux paralympiques a été
deux fois champion paralympique de
basket il faut aussi la natation mais il
ya toujours le sourire ces gens-là nous
donne une leçon quoi nous on a deux bras
deux jambes une tête qui fonctionne on
n'a pas l'aura de se plaindre faut y
aller avant de partir à l'entraînement
ce qu'est ce que vous laissez sage même
si on a un petit bobo avant de partir à
l'entraînement il faut aussi penser aux
sportifs aux sportifs handicapés qui eux
ne se posent pas de questions avant
d'aller faire des efforts on revit à
travers ce livre aussi les événements
sportifs yvelinois les grands évènements
je pense au tour de france par exemple
et c'est d'actualité parce que en boucle
est passée par le département des
yvelines
il ya plusieurs anecdotes bien vous
faire raconter quelques anecdotes 1978
dernière étape de la grande boucle
vallée de chevreuse will be no way gt gt
posté dans un virage de la vallée de
chevreuse et que mon petit appareil
photo non à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse
j'étais dans le viseur le virage le plus
serré et tout le monde m'avait dit la
dernière étape il se passe rien ça va
arriver groupé tranquille mais qu'est ce
que je vois hinault et les août au mal
qui avait attaqué hinault dans sa roue
et donc voilà il était détaché du
peloton et donc j'avais la photo lino et
zoug thomas lequel le blaireau en pleine
bagarre derrière le peloton en tout de
suite je suis allé porter salalah la
rédaction et tout c'était à chartres le
pokémon prévu un beau soutenu tous ces
souvenirs sont compilés dans cet ouvrage
vous aimait beaucoup le sport vous
l'avez pratiqué aussi oui mais je me
sers du quelques jours quel sport vous
auriez aimé faire au plus haut niveau
à bas le football bien sûr le football
avec les lunettes c'était pas possible
j'ai toujours joué au football au lycée
j'étais interne au lycée bonaparte qui
joue au football en scolaire le mercredi
à l'époque elle dimanche en club
ensuite j'ai joué avec le dimanche matin
avec les avocats du barreau de
versailles
là je peux mais maintenant je suis de la
course à pied ou si je faisais de la
course à pied en compétition
je fais du sens que ça va permettre en
cas d j'ai été champion de saône et
loire mais football et sa célébration je
regarde même quand j'étais journaliste
sportive j'ai même d'aller voir les
tournois de jeunes je cherchais ce
qu'avait des bons gestes techniques je
veux des fois autant de plaisir à
regarder les sports de division
départementale que l'équipe de france ou
du match de championnat de d1 avant de
conclure cet entretien on va juste faire
une petite pause avec notre micro
trottoir du jour question du jour quel
est le souvenir sportif qui vous a le
plus marqué vos réponses montrent très
très longtemps quand je jouais en ont
peu l'espoir je crois à toulouse qu'est
ce que j'ai fait 3g en chine et une
série de neuf paniers à trois points
mais mon plus beau souvenir c'est une
ahmed ali 64 ans je suis très tout ce
qui est sport de combat dont ils ont
tous peur du combat c'est des gens comme
ça qui m'impressionne à ce sont toutes
les médailles de mon fils en natation
voilà ben pas moi c'est que je suis
italien la demande de l'italie de 2006
on va être banal on va dire la coupe du
monde 98 mais c'est pas celui-là c'est
en fait c'est la ville où ni quand il a
passé le record de bubka qui va faire
mieux maintenant on a tous des petites
anecdotes sportive on se souvient
toujours de d'événements qui nous ont
marqué deux choses pour conclure cet
entretien tout d'abord cet ouvrage il y
aura des dédicaces qui seront organisées
dès ce week end je vais leur donner
samedi à rambouillet maison de la presse
vous serez vous y serez présent et puis
si vous voyagez un peu pour les vacances
au salon du livre de port vendres haut à
carnac du 25 au 26 juillet puis le salon
du livre à rambouillet à la rentrée
ensuite la viande eu plus de temps et
c'est important cet ouvrage parce que
vous allez faire d'ondés
les recettes oui tous mes droits
d'auteur ses écrits sont destinés à une
association pour l'accueil du milite
depuis plus de dix ans s'est associé en
lumière du monde qui a son siège à
rambouillet mais qui consiste à
construire des puits d'eau potable au
cameroun on a déjà équipé de vie de
village bayangam et bong fokam et là
c'est la troisième ville est ce qu'on
est en train d'équiper après il ya
encore des projets de c'est vraiment dur
parce que la bad dans les villages de la
brousse et n'y a pas d'hopital ils
apprennent le français ils ont aucun
matériel scolaire et dans les
dispensaires n'y a pas de médicaments
qu'il vous cet ouvrage vous ferez une
bonne oeuvre en plus une bonne action et
vous vivrez lé grand événement sportif
de ces quarante dernières années et même
les les plus anodins mais qui ont marqué
forcément on parle ces sportifs
handicapés tout à l'heure et de leur
détermination merci bernard delattre
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve demain à mercredi aux horaires
habituels à suivre sur tv fils tout de
suite le 7-8 société dernier numéro de
la saison pour cette émission de débat
consacré aux rythmes scolaires à demain